real fast food should always grab your
attention with big gutsy flavors
fantastic Aromas and be immediately
satisfying
it should also be easy to make and quick
to cook and real fast food doesn't get
much faster than my first dish
chicken stir-fry with rice noodles some
of the best street food I've ever eaten
was in Asia every one of those little
markets was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an Asian staple noodles learn to cook
those properly and you'll be surprised
how quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner
first off we're going to soak our
noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water over the
rice noodles soak
and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got to Wok perfect if not just a normal
size frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin and to cut it into strips take
your knife keep it nice and flat on the
board and sort of slice it in half like
a sort of scallop
like that we call this butterflying the
chicken take a rolling pin
and listen gently roll over the chicken
what it does it sort of flattens it
allows you to slice it even thinner
and the thinner the slice of the chicken
the sort of crisper it gets the quicker
it Cooks slice it in half
start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily
next wash your knife and finely slice
garlic
a thinner the garlic
crispier
this is a young
tender broccoli just slice them down
I want to bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables and one third of your protein
chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil get a pan really nice and
ready
just starting to smoke drop the chicken
in first
the salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
[Music]
once you've started to sear off the
chicken
get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
and see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because it colors
and Cooks at the same time as well
really really crucial
now that guard is getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
kill strange putting raw broccoli in
like that normally with Blanchard and
boiling water dry it out but you want
that crunch now soy sauce that helps to
season it but also stains beautifully
soy sauce in
lovely
that's exactly what I want now take that
out
give you a pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
what really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing this quick stir fry very
classic two eggs in
[Music]
whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of almost
spread it at the side of the pan
lightly season the eggs noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give that
a really nice mix
you want the egg to sort of almost bring
the dish together
the eggs cooked
make sure you're that nice even
distribution of
chicken broccoli garlic
lovely
and then just finish that that fresh
line and there you have a very simple
delicious stir fry with rice noodles
foreign
gets his name because it's cooked and
eaten on the streets from the Hawker
markets in Asia to the New York hot dog
stands there are some great chefs out
there serving seriously delicious food
that you can eat on the go
my first recipe is a special mix of
fantastic flavors from around the world
beef tacos with Wasabi Mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the Only Rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos makes a Mexican and
Japanese flavors into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot these are sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
they'll add flavor
salt and pepper
a couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot
hold of the steak
and lay it in always lay away
to the panel a little shake and it stops
the steak from sticking we're looking
for color
and if it sticks it's going to burn
while the steaks are cooking I can go
with my super quick marinade now
two tablespoons of
me soup paste that's a fermented soybean
that gives a really nice sort of Rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar a couple tablespoons
rice wine that gives it a really nice
fengary kick a couple of tablespoons of
olive oil
salt and pepper
I'm looking for a nice sort of thick
Rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
I saw the pan
into the other space still based all
we're doing every time is just adding
more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really melt all
that fat down
off with the gas
take them out just take your knife
seal that fat there just slice that off
any of that
now in
to the marinade
[Music]
useful
tacos are one of Mexico's most popular
Street Foods they've been made from beef
poor chicken or fish and I'll loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now I want something sort of pickly
cabbage these are Chinese cabbages slice
it in half
and look at it really crisp and really
tasty
I'm going to slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
think of cabbage here and you think
you're sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but attacker you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly give it a little
bit of heat
a little touch of rice wine vinegar if
you haven't got that fresh lemon juice
small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now I need something to sort of bring it
together we take some Wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
I'm going to mix that
a couple of tablespoons of mayonnaise
give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them actually place it
on
the guest room
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan from there
I'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin literally 30 seconds
as it cools down the great thing about
serving tacos is people can feel them
themselves just the way they want them
cabbage just squeeze out wet marinade
nice rustic Little Mountain
mayonnaise on
what did you see how soft and delicious
and almost sort of melting in the mouth
texture we've got on this amazing
sirloin so I've got that really nice
see you around the outside
just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my crispy shell back of
the spoon with the Wasabi mayonnaise
inside taco
just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my attacker for three or
four slices
touch more
am I spicy
Maya
that is how I'd make
the perfect attacker
[Music]